hey guys Pete here are you ready for
Westworld season two we've got the new
trailer today and we got a short version
of it in the Super Bowl and then a
longer version released online right
after we found out that the release date
for Westworld season 2 is April most of
us had already guessed that since
jeffrey wright had made a bit of a slip
and mention that on twitter but now we
know that officially i'm gonna break
this down like I do everything Westworld
related and pick up right where I left
off last year so let's jump into it the
trailer starts with an aerial view of
the river we see a distance shot of the
train rolling into town with a couple
more landscape shots thrown in there and
then we see one of the natives roll up
on his horse remember the last time we
saw Stubbs he was being run down by
these guys we see a flashback to Maeve
walking with her daughter which we've
seen a bunch of times it's the same
footage from the first season just
sandwiched in there then we see a wide
shot of what looks like the Abernathy
herd too far away to see who's in the
picture but it just looks like farmhands
from there we go to this awesome looking
slow-motion shot of these Bulls we don't
know much more about them yet at this
point but we're gonna see some more of
that in a bit
with more cuts of the ranch some people
riding on a ridge here and a shot from
behind a character who I'm not exactly
sure who it is
we also see them riding on a horse and
we all take note of what the clothes
look like so maybe we can figure out who
that is later this is cut back and forth
between the bulls attacking we see that
they are hosts Bulls that they are
attacking what looks like the regular
delos staff inside the post development
center we see that they're basically
running down these guys and they're
shooting at the Bulls but it's probably
not doing much good
we have a shot of Bernard slash Arnold
Bernhard old walking and it looks like
Stubbs is with him this is probably cut
from the same thing that we saw in the
first teaser when they were riding in
like the dune buggy they're assessing
something and it's the people who are
left I guess from the security detail of
Delos Incorporated we see what looks
like burne Arnold looking down on the
water from above and I'm guessing that
these are all dead animals that are
inside it I say this because of the
first teaser where we saw him standing
next to a dead tiger this could be in
that same sequence but it's not sure
then we get one of the most interesting
shots of the teaser trailer for me which
is Peter Abernathy's character he
strapped to a chair and there are people
restraining him and what's so
interesting about this to me is is that
he was in cold storage and you remember
that he was going to be the vessel for
the information that they wanted to get
out of the park Lisa oz Mora was going
to make him a passable host with a bunch
of data on his hard drive I guess you
could say and now we see him looking
like he is being detained and we can
speculate quite a bit about what's going
on there we have a quick shot of a civil
war looking a bunch of guys there which
should be related to the Wyatt storyline
and then we get another one of the big
interesting clips which is Byrne Arnold
looking at something and a faceless host
sneaking up behind him looking like he
was going to attack there's also a quick
blast of what looks like teddy being
approached from behind with someone's
hand over his mouth and then we get our
first shot of Logan who looks like he's
gone outside of the park he's got a
party he's dressed up looks like he's
with a lot of important people here and
this kind of hints that we might see how
the transition of the park from dr. Ford
to Delos Goes Down which would be
interesting to learn more about that
backstory I mean we know Jimmy Simpson
is supposed to be back we know
guns back obviously so so that could be
a good side story there is what what
they did outside in the world it gives
us a little more idea of where this
whole West world thing came from and
where those guys come from whenever they
come to visit the park a couple of short
present day man in black clips there he
looks a little concerned at Harris does
we see more action going on by where the
hosts are produced and we see Clementine
standing there with her hand up against
the window watching it all go down the
bulls appear to be winning as you would
expect they would the staff looks to
beginning overwhelmed and run down and
as we're bearing witness to their
destruction we see Maeve come down and
it's just a super awesome shot the glass
is breaking in slow-motion she's moving
down the hallway calmly dressed all in
black as the bulls are wreaking havoc on
the staff probably the best and most
exciting shot of the trailer for me
because this is what we've been waiting
for since last season there's a couple
shots of why it's gang moving with
torchlight in the nighttime and then we
see this awesome
sequence that we saw in the first teaser
with Dolores riding on horseback
shooting what looks to be humans who are
still in the park now of course there is
narration throughout and it is Dolores
his voice she talks about how beautiful
the world is she talks about how they
built the world and now they need to
destroy it more or less because humans
have made it into their world and it's
not supposed to be that way this sets
the tone we saw this in the first teaser
but we see that there really is a
concerted effort led by Dolores to
attack humans and we see that maybe is
moving through the center neutralizing
the staff who worked there the aftermath
of dr. Ford's going-away party is there
we see there are plenty of corpses
laying around although it doesn't show
anybody directly
so we figured that there's probably
knowing that we would have expected to
be a main character laying in that pile
of bodies we do see the wolf go by which
we've seen quite a bit in the first
season after that there's a shot of
Dolores walking with Bernard and she
does not look like Dolores she's dressed
in what looks to be modern clothing this
could be her impersonating someone who
is on the Delos staff it could be an
indication that she was going to leave
the park but I don't think that's the
case based on everything else we've seen
in this but it is interesting to see
that she's not wearing her normal
Dolores skier Maeve and Hector are
standing outside somewhere and we see
her either catch some snowflakes or some
ashes in her hand she's looking around
we don't really see what Hector's up to
he's just sort of in the background and
then it cuts two more hosts
on human violence at the centre some
guys here hosts for sure with some
interesting masks on their face they're
sort of like black things I thought this
may have been something to do with the
man in black by after we see the
continuation of Bernard being attacked
by this faceless host and thrown into
something some kind of machine that's
used for building the hosts we get a
real good close-up of Dolores and she
seems to be surrounded by these guys
with the hoods on their faces again and
that is where the trailer ends just a
ton of stuff in that little one minute
and 39 second run most of its new I did
read before this came out that some of
it is exclusive to this trailer as in
this isn't footage from season two what
would be that I have no idea I watched
this several times obviously before I
started taking the screenshots and I
didn't really have anything jump out to
me as being like okay this is the
trailer only stuff let me know if you
guys saw something in there and I will
definitely respond to you in the
comments I can't be any more hype than I
am right now I was very excited to begin
with
I've been waiting it was kind of like
crazy waiting for the trailer to finally
come out but now it's here and
the teaser was really great to get us
excited but it's been so long since the
comic-con that this is really making it
seem like we're almost there so I'm
gonna be picking up with plenty of more
Westworld season 2 videos in the run-up
to the season coming out then I'll be
doing my regular episode recap and
reviews trailer breakdowns bonus videos
and we'll be going through the whole
season together so make sure you like
this video if you enjoyed it make sure
you subscribe to my channel now and then
set notifications so you can keep up
with all the latest uploads
I have several about the news and
different things that came out during
filming that I want to get out and also
just anything that pops up in the news
between now and then you can follow me
on my Twitter and other social media
accounts I'm easy to contact that way
and if you want to help support the
channel I would love it if you'd come
and visit my patreon and try to get
involved over there it's getting harder
and harder to support a YouTube channel
just through Adsense revenue which I'm
sure that you know alright that's it for
now guys thanks for watching I will talk
to you soon